or structured this is a with Sean bass
and Sir John and basically what we would
do trying to do is we were trying to
take these snacks which have trusted set
up and we were trying to ask ourselves
is there a better way to do this trusted
set up so we're not getting rid of it
entirely but we're trying to mitigate
the trust concerns to the point where
they are not a concern well hopefully
not a concern
why do we want snacks over other
protocols I mean certainly you saw that
there are lots of choices when it comes
to zero knowledge this morning and
snacks have some trade-offs which are
better in some cases and worse in other
cases but one thing that they have which
is very nice
is that verification is very very small
so typically you would be talking a
couple of powering equations
proof and that would be at whereas in
other schemes you almost always have
this logarithmic factor going on where
you're going to be trying to represent
the circuit in some kind of way where
the verify is going to query and then
the person is going to respond and this
overhead that you're going to get from
that for some applications it might not
be a problem but for other applications
where you're verifier might be very time
constrained you are you might be in a
situation where you're willing to accept
a slightly high approver for example and
slightly less nice assumptions in order
to get that down
the problem that we have with these
snacks is that they have to have a
trusted set up and what we mean here is
that zero knowledge necessarily by
definition has a chapter in any
construction you care to mention there
will exist some trap door which can be
used to forge proofs so that doesn't
mean that you will be able to tell the
difference between this proof and that
prove this witness that witness it
cannot be used to break anonymity but it
can be used to break integrity all of
the time and this is quite serious like
if you can break the integrity of your
zero knowledge proof why are you using
your zero knowledge proof in the first
place so you're just calling integrity
as
because okay maybe you're in the
situation where you do have some magical
party in the sky that's totally trusted
who's not going to put it corrupt your
skiing there's often times you don't you
don't trust anyone and now we're stuck
in a situation where we have a scheme
which we essentially can't use first of
course I wouldn't be talking here if
that was actually the case certainly if
we're talking proofs which aren't snot
proofs but things like Phillips proofs
things like Starks what they have is
they have a transparent set up so that
means even though they're technically
exists a trapdoor the way the parameters
are chosen is that random and therefore
we are able to take a randomized
algorithm where we release all of the
public coins and put that into the setup
and then we're fairly sure that what
comes out of the setup is going to make
it so that nobody knows the trapdoor
still exists but nobody knows it in the
sense that there exists some proof maybe
you can say that fabulous is built into
the design of shuttle 56 but in practice
if you see a stark with randomness of
the old zero string it would still not
be broken in practical sense right I
mean in the case of Starks I'm thinking
about it as the simulator would have a
way to manipulate the hash function
because that is what the simulator does
in the proof so they would have some
kind of way to program the hash function
to give it the answer that they wanted
something about your knowledge of
something
it's on this list of the things I'm
familiar with is proved in
non-programmable if you have a thorough
knowledge scheme then you will have a
simulator so there will be at least one
party who is able to cheat
listen you later yes but because you
have zero knowledge that does impact
your sound this snuck parameters over
these dark parameters that you were
talking abouts and certainly lots of
other schemes is that they are not
actually chosen at random they have a
very high degree of structure and we
have to somehow find a way to generate
parameters with these structure such
that we can still build proofs but that
nobody knows the underlying elements
which have been used
to illustrate that if you have music
parameters you're going to have just a
mess you're going to have lots of things
which are chosen at random or as if you
have snap parameters you're going to be
very carefully constructing them to be
exactly of the format that you want
so how can we use these snacks if we're
now in a situation where their
parameters are difficult to generate
essentially what we're going to do is
we're going to do a multi-party
computation in order to generate the
parameters so we're going to need lots
and lots of parties taking part and we
want to be able to say that provided one
of these parties is honest then nobody
in the entire scheme can know the
trapdoor and it doesn't matter where
that honest pass party happens to offer
to participate it
so here each participant is going to
learn just a little bit of the secret
and you need all of the secrets to put
together in order to be able to
construct the trapdoor in order to be
able to build the simulator to break the
snack
so in prior works it used to be the case
that the way people would do this if
they were to do an MPC for each
individual application which they were
trying to build so you would have one
set up for range proofs one set up for
the Akash one set up coder and any other
application you care to name and each of
these companies are running these things
would have to do their own their own
ceremony in order to get their own
parameters and what's more if they got
it wrong if they happen to somewhere in
their code have mistakenly forgot a
minus sign they then have to run the
whole ceremony again which is like not
just a theoretical concern I think this
is quite a practical concern because
mistakes happening all the time
so the difference that we have in Sonic
setup is that it is universal and this
means provided your setup is OK which is
a big provided but assuming it is you
can then take the parameters from that
and you can build any application which
you care to think of
up to a given size we do have a size
bound but provided you can represent
your scheme within this number of
constraints if you need to make a change
that's fine just change it
so in previous setups the way they would
do it is in this sort of two round
protocol so they would start off with
some kind of reference string someone
would come along and add a little bit
more of it to the secrets underlying the
reference strings this is called an
update in order to generate the next
trip somebody else would come in there
take the second reference string and
then they would update it again in order
to produce the third reference string
okay and the thing is this first phase
does not depend on the circuit whereas
they needed something which does depend
on the circuit so they would then go
into a phase two and once you start
phase two you cannot edit phase one
and phase two is going to work much the
same way but you start with something
which is already structured and then you
update on your structured thing but you
cannot change the thing that you start
with without rerunning around one thanks
to this guy's fixed sonic we get rid of
the second round so we can just use the
first round with these global reference
strings no dependence on the application
for whatever we happen to be building
the system I was describing here where
you have one person update with the next
person update then the next person
update we call this prophecy update
ability and yeah what it means is that
if one party at any point in time is not
colluding with all other parties then
the resulting parameters will be fine
which means that if you have a
particularly distrustful user who says I
don't think that your setup is okay I
think that every single one of you is
colluding you could theoretically just
incorporate them into the setup without
it being a big deal
but one downside is we cannot make any
guarantees about the security of the
snacks which were created before the
honest party participated update proofs
are very very small and we don't need to
store the reference strings we only need
to store the update proofs so we need
the final reference string and we need
the reference strings which you use to
verify things but these are also quite
small the actual in-between steps with
these linear size reference strings we
don't need to keep those around which is
quite a nice property
our actual reference strings which we're
going to be using our linear sized so
this is essentially equal to the output
of one of the trusted setups of sacred
16
so only the current reference ring needs
to be stored and we have got the
parameters down to the size where they
could be stored verified and updated on
a personal laptop you wouldn't need to
have any kind of distributed system in
order to get these parameters
if we're talking about actually doing
these things where the verifier is
smaller than the prover then this is
actually impossible because the verifier
needs to read the program the way we get
around this is that we have this sort of
one time director evasion process where
we take in the output of the trusted
set-up we do some kind of public
computation to it in order to get some
structure into there and that's the
actual reference string that we'll be
using for this application specific
thing
so if we're talking sonic then sonic
does do this and we get proofs which are
constant sized but actually the
asymptotics aren't that great it's not
the asymptotic so the practical
constants aren't that great
they're quite quite large it was a
feasibility result this part
but where we do get good constants and
where we are in a situation where we're
able to say we are competitive with the
state of the art to use asking is when
you're not just producing one proof but
you're producing many many many many
many proofs so if you're thinking
cryptocurrencies these are a classic
example of that if you're a node you're
not going to be verifying a single
transaction you're going to be given all
of the transactions in a block and
you're going to verify them all at the
same time and if you're doing that the
miss is precisely the kind of situation
where Sonic is going to help you
is we're gonna have fruit one-by-one
easier PI 2 pi 3 these are all generated
by different parties ok
oh they could be generated by the same
party it doesn't matter and then you're
going to have some kind of aggregating
party or helpers were calling them
but the aggregator isn't here to reduce
proof size they are here to reduce
verifier time so what they're going to
do is they're going to compute some kind
of advice string
and then our actual verifier
with access to the advice string
with the proofs
is going to tie running a time which is
constant in the number of proofs and
depending on the size of the circuit as
a one-off cost when it's checking the
advice provided both check out you get
something which is very efficient in
this batch setting
in the cash setting right who's gonna
update the CRS and so if the probe we're
gonna use the that last updated service
yeah but maybe they don't trust I mean
know which serious issue deals right
maybe there were the women thousands of
updates okay say you definitely were I
probably wouldn't post the actual
reference strings on the blockchain I
guess you could be pretty inefficient I
would probably just post a semi
appointed to the way you can find it and
then if you're looking for the update
proofs these you can store on your
laptop and you could very much have it
so that somebody else who has
participated in the scheme and point to
their proof and say that proof is mine
because the update proof said they're
small they're like three proof elements
there are three elements
no I mean when I'm proving do I also
have to indicate which Cirrus I'm using
because there are assuming that would
need to be some consensus about which
which reference ring you're using yes
finally advanced which series or cooler
so using yes I think we should I mean
this is something where you can every
now and again maybe once a day say move
to the next reference string move to the
next reference string but I don't I
think in terms of like actually making
it so that the system run very smoothly
having it so that people we're all using
the same reference string would be
certainly much better if we're wanting
to do this aggregating trick ya know
because so my Fuhrer was the whole point
of this updating is that I don't trust
anybody but I want to make my own update
and the very fires that's the point of
it I would say the point is that with an
MPC you have to you have some fairly
strict time deadlines on when you have
to have completed your MPC by where it's
with our one we can run it over an
entire year if we want to in order to
get special
we don't have to have this sort of thing
where the focus round ends and second
round begins I certainly wouldn't go
live with the system if I wasn't sure
that there have been enough updates put
it that way I mean later in time if you
don't trust the set up that someone did
ten years ago you can still update again
so we can just in terms of like
intuition of how you gonna do this are
you thinking like I want to create a new
block chain I'm just gonna start with
the trusted set up with an existing
block chain and I'd have much more set
up but then it's people trusted the
original blockchain emissions little
trust mine or are you thinking like this
thing changes every year and if so so
you have like a pre sign transaction
submitted
so you would have to keep the reference
string under which the signature was
generated around but you could
potentially have like a single watching
where you're verifying proofs under two
different reference I mean I'm not sure
you'd want to but you could well I'm
just saying sometimes you want to like
have a transaction but not submit it so
it's like the reference string under
which these proofs it's gonna like
change every year or something that
could be annoying someone anybody it
would be annoying once a minute would be
annoying but once a year with right
December someone gives you something
you're going to submit for watching
three months maybe I have a time lock
transaction where it like pays out we
can only submit it in three months but
that's a private transaction
Weiss is the recipient could actually
read
so the assumptions we're making about
these health is that they is that they
have a fairly large amount of
computational results not ridiculously
large but they are going to have to do a
linear amount of work per prover
we do not want to trust them if we
trusted them it would almost ruin the
point of doing the proofs in the first
place we want them to verify every
single thing that they're telling us so
we are also assuming that helpers cannot
communicate with the original provers
and this is quite a big restriction this
limits of ways and well it's it's a good
thing but in terms of building the proof
it made it a bit harder but in terms of
actually using the proofs it makes it a
lot easier it means you don't have to
have some kind of interaction channel
going between the prover and the helper
and they can aggregate proofs to reduce
of our highs I have had the sense of
cannot here is not it's not shall not
it's more like does not meet - I don't
like China applications you'd probably
make it - jutsu I can see other
applications for example if you have a
very parallel prover where you would
make it prove is responsibility in my
case
we have M constant size proofs and one
helper proof the helper proof requires
linear work to verify but this is a
one-off cost and the constant size
proofs that's going to cost M times the
number of previous in order to verify
them
so with this helper we can achieve very
good concrete efficiency not just in
terms of verifier time but also proof
size we have four group elements to
field elements which is so the state of
the art in the non universal case it's
about 16 which is three group elements
so we're about double that but not more
john implemented it he also helped the
designer was a big part in designing the
scheme but I cannot take any credit for
the implementation is what I mean when I
say I'm saying that and it can be found
on the address EPC
and when we were taking timings we were
finding pretty much what we were
expecting we were finding that when you
had this helped verify the amount that
they had to spend an effort verifying
the individual proofs was very very low
but we were paying some overhead in
terms approver time this is standard for
snacks they usually have quite quite
heavy duty provers and again I hope ERV
was impacted by the size of the circuit
this is expected
recently Chiron and others from Z cash
introduced a way in which you could
implement Sonic without a trusted setup
the idea is that you take they're very
much using this helper setting if you
don't have a helper than the trips
they're using here do not work but if
you do have a helper than what they do
is a notice that the bulletproof
verifier is something which you can
generate an advice string for and if you
have the advice string then you can
check all of the bulletproof proofs in
one go
I was making the individual marginal
custody that's what we were calling them
quite small
so if we don't have a help I mentioned
before that we're not doing so great
here in terms of proof size it's not too
bad but the proof of time is very very
high to the point where I every single
time where I count it I get a different
result don't trust the numbers in the
paper too much
recently there have been two works which
have been introduced which try and
tackle this problem one of which I am a
co-author on with ally and others and
this is where specifically for the
certain way you don't have helper and
this might for example happen when
you're trying to verify the output of
the random beacon if you have a random
beacon then you're only going to have
something you need to verify once every
well because I only output things every
now and again so you definitely don't
want to be in a situation where you can
only prove things of fashion efficiently
if you have a helper because you only
have one proof so in this setting Mullen
managed to get the prover down to
roughly four times the state of the art
in the non Universal setting and we were
pretty pleased for this again proofs are
constant sized and the way we did it was
with a derivation process where we were
taking our one CS matrix and we were
having an indexer which is able to only
pick out the relevant entries in the
matrix whereas with Sonic we weren't
able to do that if you have a very
sparse matrix and then you would end up
having to have a polynomial commitment
scheme now take that into account and it
would all get difficult so we introduced
a permutation argument to get around
that and it got quite messy whereas this
was a much cleaner approach
and both approaches we are using a
polynomial commitment scene big trick
get something by kati numbers you send a
polynomial someone responds with a
challenge and you say this is output of
the polynomial and you check it first we
have a sonnet we had a bivariate
polynomial and this was a really really
technical challenging thing about the
paper but how do you deal with bivariate
polynomials so we have something of the
form s of X Y it's a public polynomial
there's no secrets in it but the verify
has to know its evaluation at some point
so essentially the way we did this is we
took in the help setting we take in lots
of polynomials well committed
polynomials at lots of points and we try
to say how do we know that these
commitments are correct
so faster both
verifier same polynomial evaluated at
multiple points lots of the same
polynomial evaluated on multiple points
hash them in order to get some kind of
challenge or Oracle response and then
we're going to commit
and then we're going to need to send a
proof a commitment to s of Zed Y is
correct
and we're also going to need to check
that the opening of s of Zed y at y1 is
equal to the opening of s of X Y one
that said nothing for this one the same
for that one all the way along and the
trick here is that they can only be
equal if they were if the original one
was in fact computed correctly and the
proof that this thing is completed
correctly
well it's linear you only have to check
at once
just to sum up trusted setups can be
instantiated badly and when they are
instantiated badly they are bad news but
there are ways where you can do them
well and if you do do a very carefully
thought-out just a setup where you're
picking deciding how people are taking
part very carefully and you're making
sure that it's a very open and
transparent process and this is much
easier to do with a setup which is
updatable and universal certainly
because if you have many setups for many
different applications then then you
know auditors would have to check all of
your different setups whereas in this
case I only have to check one where they
helper sonic has very small concrete
overhead and without so help there are
other systems some of which I think you
might hear about later this week which
have some good concrete overhead
[Applause]
so we started from the bulletproof
skiing and we embedded one of the
challenges but not both because usually
you would embed both challenges when
building stats but this time we only
embedded one into the common reference
string and then after we embedded one we
were there saying how can you check that
the rest of the stuff is valid and this
is where we were really struggling with
this a bivariate polynomial because even
though it's sparse the sparseness
doesn't help you if you're trying to
commit to it because polynomial
commitments and bivariate things
quadratic but by being able to take it
into the random Oracle model and say if
you have all of these things and you
want to prove that they computed
correctly at the same time can you do
that we realize that actually this was
very doable
so this n on the board how does that
relate to like a computation the number
of things that you're aggregating
so if you're only aggregating one thing
but if you're aggregating ten things it
gets better and if you are aggregating a
hundred things it gets better and more
thing to aggregating the better it is
for the mirror so yeah we're not
shrinking proof size anything appear
size varies a little bit but we are
making it so that was very happy I have
to do much less work how many number of
Cruces
that probably depends on the size of
your circuit actually so it would be
hard to give you a precise number
because certainly if you're just talking
one proof then even though I work it's
linear it would still be linear in the
field rather than learning in terms of
exponentiation so maybe that bad so you
probably would more be seeing the
effects with very large circuits and the
larger the circuit the more proofs
you're going to need sorry the smaller
the circuit the more proofs you're going
to need before it comes to effort
[Applause]